[Musique]
salut casimir
bonjour joli petit moi ça n'a pas l'air
d'aller très fort bon tu es des ennuis
non tu es malade je ne crois pas mais
qu'est ce que tu as là je ne sais pas
très bien tu es triste et tu ne sais pas
pourquoi je ne suis pas vraiment triste
mais je n'arrive pas à être gay avait
alors fait quelque chose
remue toit sont denses je n'en n'ai ni
l'envié ni le courage
alors c'est grave voilà françois va
peut-être nous donner une explication
les sanglots longs des violons de
l'automne terres à quinze jours julie
dit long je suis en train de lire des
poèmes merveilleux et par exemple ces
vers de paul verlaine un peu les
sanglots longs des violons de l'automne
vers son coeur une langueur monotone
c'est bon les spas et oui mais françois
je voudrais te caf en est ce que tu peux
répéter ce que tu viens de dire non
c'est ce que je viens de lire casimir
c'est pas nous a malheureusement non ce
sont de très beaux vers de paul verlaine
ils vont casimir tu t'intéresses à la
poésie maintenant je te demande
simplement de relire cette phrase mais
bien volontiers casimir les sanglots
longs des violons de l'automne
berceau au coeur d'une langueur monotone
c'est ça c'est exactement ça mais de
quoi parles-tu bears mon coeur d'une
langueur monotone
c'est exactement ce que je ressens ils
peuvent nous pouv casimir tu es bien
malade
mais dis donc tu te sens comme ça depuis
quand depuis sur ce matin et et dur sans
vraiment ce qu'écrivait verlaine
ah oui des sanglots longs qui berce mon
coeur d'une langueur monotone mais quasi
mais c'est extraordinaire ça tu sais que
tu as une véritable âme de pauleta
parce que justement aujourd'hui et bien
c'est le début d'automne policière mais
oui parfaitement
mais nous y sommes pourquoi mais nous
parce que françois dit n'importe quoi
souviens-toi joly s'est déjà passé
l'automne
il ya longtemps c'était juste avant
l'hiver tout souvenir sevré casimir mais
aujourd'hui c'est de nouveau l'automne
on quand il ya quatre saisons tu sais 4
seulement
oui le printemps l'été l'automne et
l'hiver
mais alors pourquoi est-ce que l'on
chante toujours dans l'île aux enfants
c'est tous les jours le printemps mais
ça c'est une façon de parler
mais oui tu sais bien que dans notre île
il fait toujours beau mais est plutôt
chaud mais dans les autres pays et
particulièrement en france
chaque saison à des aspects très
particulier je suis sûr que les enfants
vont pouvoir te l'expliquer oui moi j'ai
moins de la bonne idée jolie quand c'est
cette histoire de quatre saisons
c'est par contre l'activité vous êtes
d'accord les enfants vous avez vu
casimir ne sais pas ce que sont les
quatre saisons
vous vous les connaissez alors c'est
quoi déjà des quatre saisons
et ben voilà
patricia tu peux me parler du printemps
que se passe-t-il à pantin il ya
beaucoup de fleurs oui
les arbres sont en fleurs arbres sont en
fleurs
la température ça commence à changer un
ça commence à changer
et puis aussi comment s'habille tôt on
était un peu plus légèrement on commence
à s'habiller plus légèrement l'éternité
dans le quartier leclerc
oui c'est bien ma mère parce qu'elle
fait déjà les fleurs qui n était qu est
ce qu elle devait soulever ici tout son
sens
mais c'est sa nature it et de la nature
alors on a vu le printemps l'été ça
brille c'est tu veux nous parler de
l'automne elle atteint ya beaucoup de
sites en ou rose art oui et puis il fait
pas très chaud
j'ai pas très chaud il se passera
beaucoup de temps on est plein c'est
vrai à bien
est-ce que tu as remarqué que les
couleurs dans la campagne change oui les
jeunes gens me sens parce que les
feuilles sont en train de mourir après
avoir été verte
voilà très bien ces crèmes en quatrième
qu'est-ce que ça c'est l'envers soit oui
ces univers quatrième d'accord livia
missisquoi qui s'étale et la plus
bizarre et le lui on les a bien jouées
puis quand il pleut peut-être c'est tout
bien alors quinzaine et ses traits au
printemps été automne hiver le contre et
maintenant nous c'est tellement facile
alors bon il n'a plus investi qu'aucune
sava dont je sais très bien maintenant
donc le printemps des feuillants bah
quoi ça écoutez vous êtes d'accord
qui dit ne pas attendre il faut s'en
méfier il y as souvent de la neige à
moto il y a des bourgeons sur les arbres
en hiver il fait très chaud
vous êtes d'accord et santé se sont
enfin dit non
vous allez tout regarder mais c'est
michel de chanteurs de bonnes surprises
au salut michel tu nous chante une
chanson ça doyon casimir tout ça chez
lui ce arrivé tranquillement
d'ailleurs il semble qu'ils n'aient pas
très envie de chanter c'est vrai j'ai un
peu le cafard
mais bonjour comme ça c'est comme moi
c'est à cause de l'automne on ferait
casimir chez certains que michel a une
autre raison n'est ce pas non c'est
aussi à cause de l'automne que je joue
ça me rend triste c'est l'arrivée de
l'automne aujourd'hui et je suis très
triste parce que c'est la fin des
vacances et maintenant elles sont bien
finies j'ai été sur sur la côte d'azur
dans le midi de la france et j'ai
rencontré un copain formidable on s'est
baigné toute la journée on a joué toute
la journée
puis il a dû repartir vers le nord c'est
une triste histoire au point vraiment je
suis certaine qu'il reviendra l'été
prochain mais aussi alors pour qu'il
oublie pas je l'écris une chanson
[Applaudissements]
le soleil
porter malade
la mère a mis dans son port tous les
voiliers
les voiliers de reims entre les moutons
le vent
[Musique]
tu
l'été
quand
non
dans les
on les lit
tu
m
pelé jamais repartie
dans mon amour et son
chiendent perdu tout ça
la nuit je
satwa
entraîneur à
non
peut-être qu'en
[Musique]
le vent
peut-être
quand
[Musique]
dans les chansons les
ah ah
c
les
mais
raté
tu
[Musique]
et
accor
il
non
ça va
jamais repartie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]